season two with love yes what is your
vision this year's horny it's a horny
year
there is so much more spiciness this
season it's a lot of spice I asked
Gloria what can I expect in season two
her answer very blunt to the camera sex
horny she literally said it's a horny
season guys we've been through a lot we
have we've been through a lot you know
what I mean burn off the sexual tensions
we need to I think we need a little sexy
fun you know don't we you're nodding
yeah we do we need sexy fun I have it
for you sexy fun coming your way
happy birthday to me did you go skinny
dipping we've been lurking here on your
set thank you so much for having us a
little birdie whispered in my ear about
you know what's going on for season two
and I was told that the steamy factor is
so high this season that there were
actually a few closed days on set there
yes well we're very respectful of course
of the actors in the process and we
always want to defer to them we have
this wonderful thing now in the industry
that's called a sensitivity coordinator
that comes in and they deal with all of
the intimate scenes to make sure
everyone's super super comfortable
everything's discussed beforehand it's
been pretty steamy this year okay so
what has been steamy who's getting
action kind of everyone's getting action
in different ways Nick's always getting
action Jorge and and Henry are having
lots of sexy fun we have Lily having
sexy fun with other people and with
herself because that's important we want
to destigmatize self-love for sure uh
especially for Latina women it's not
something we talk about very much and
that's it's okay oh my God you're still
in love with my sister I love you I'm
a who do you want to be with
danger zone Lily Diaz
Lily has more sex than more I guess
there's a lot let's just say there's
something in every episode yes that's
right yeah that's right and as an
actress what is that like for you I
heard there were some close sets yeah um
I mean just getting spray tan making
sure you know I'm trying to get as
healthy as possible I'm making sure
we're brushing our teeth before we kiss
yeah you know all that kind of stuff but
you know the set has been very great
with keeping making me feel safe and
um the My co-stars um are amazing at
also being super respectful and giving
me the time so it's been it's been fun
okay I am a little blessed that I get to
get to do that wait wait okay should we
stop and listen or no no we should do
something we have to do something now
come on how are you doing on the sexy
Factor well you know I think that Henry
and Jorge have always been kind of the
more PG of the couples between the the
siblings right I think that we're a
little bit more like romantic it's a
little bit more suggested like and then
they have sex you know what I mean like
it's kind of like the kissing and then
it like falls down on the bed and then
it says in the script Henry and Jorge hi
sex and I like them okay I'm just gonna
say are you jealous because you know
with it no I I I have so much respect
for our co-stars and would have no
problem
um stimulating sex with any of them it
just it you know it's weird it's awkward
you know as much as I love Vinnie who
plays Henry and and and you know we get
on so well you know I like that we stop
it like the you know the suggestion of
us having sex I don't want to wear what
I well we're on a nice program I can
talk about what goes into all of that
yes see one ended with this massive
Cliffhanger how did you decide what
couple was gonna be the one to walk down
the aisle for me it was always going to
be Henry they have great chemistry
together these two actors it's a very
loving relationship they have both have
their flaws and both have their things
but they found a way to love each other
through them and uh so I I was like
what's that going to look like and also
for the for the Latino Community you
know it's it's seeing a family love one
of their queer family members and be as
excited with all of the family drama
that comes with a wedding and planning a
wedding as they would be for a straight
family member was a really big deal I've
just never seen it you have exceeded
anything and everything that I could
have ever possibly imagined for myself
and you've made me a better person for
IT how emotional has this been did the
characters have a say in in writing
their own vows Mark and Vinnie were both
involved in what their characters were
wearing what Mark was very involved in
the wedding he really is already a a an
icon for our community because of Ugly
Betty and being the youngest you know
Latino out actor that was playing a
queer character on television so he
understands the importance and the
heaviness of that and so he wanted to
really show how gorgeous and elegant
Jorge could be or he's already a style
icon icon yes so all of the outfits what
he's wearing is amazing and they
designed it together him and Tessa that
you know our seamstress here designed it
together and it's gorgeous and the
wedding itself we went through little
books marks like I feel like I'm
planning my wedding it's such a
beautiful wedding I may or may not have
had tears what made you tear up I mean
everyone being there and I love love and
I love weddings and
it was all beautiful was it the vows
that got you I mean I don't know maybe
maybe not are things dramatic in season
two what kind of there's big hurdles are
we getting there's still some drama this
year I mean it's I think that we're
really
um I think Lily's really going on a
journey of she's one of these girls that
grew up with these promises that the the
all of the rom-coms promised her she's
30 and things are not what she thought
she thought she'd be married and have
kids by now right and I see a lot of
young people have a lot of pressure on
themselves because they're not there and
it's it's odd that we've made that such
a pressure for women to feel like we we
are only okay if we have a partner and
if we're appropriating and I say that as
someone who got married at 25. you know
like I did all those things uh and it
was great and I loved it but that
doesn't have to be everyone's journey
and then also you know her relationship
with her with her brother who she's
their best friends and they have some
some fractures this year as well she
started it he won't
in the first season Lillian Jorge really
did live the kind of picturesque
um cookie cutter sibling relationship
where they stood up for each other
they're each other's best friends and
you I mean we do wear each other where's
my
[Applause]
and that's
what I do but I do really feel strongly
about like you know their their
relationship is not cookie cutter and
their relationship is not you know it's
your ass and they have to fight they
have to
um deal with each other with things that
they don't like characteristics that
they don't necessarily like with each
other which inevitably bring them back
together even stronger than ever Lily is
really messy and she doesn't realize
sometimes she drags people along the way
that's actually hurts them and um and
she's realizing that yeah she's
realizing that and hold his making her
open her eyes to the situations where
it's not just about her and he's really
me
and I think that that's something really
like you know necessary to be said as
messy as Lily is and you know we can
make this season the roast of Lily Diaz
um you know the writers have done an
incredible job of of of of making Jorge
himself not be you know so tasteful at
times with the ways in which he comes
for her we don't want the audience to
walk away hating Lily and loving Jorge
or vice versa that's important that
there's that there's Duality to that
where it makes more sense to eat because
breakfast in bed is sweet
[Music]
I don't want these
croissant crumbs in my bed there's a lot
of romance but also there's a lot of
drama and yeah as far as my character
you know you'll see them in Miles
continue to Blossom their relationship
but you'll also see them kind of go
through hiccups along the way like any
couple and Todd my same partner is such
a Vibe so we really just have fun on set
and we get to we got to really go
through so many different emotions this
season so get the popcorn ready we're
really rooting for for Saul and Miles as
as a couple tame Smiles yes team Smiles
what can you tell me about these hiccups
and these roadblocks that lie ahead for
them I like to think that Soul before
this relationship they had so many
issues with love so you know bringing
your partner around your family
what does that mean what happens when
you're you're in love and then your
partners see the Dynamics and the family
and like what does that mean when the
Two Worlds Collide so that that may be a
a big part of our love story this season
and the story I think is so warm and so
necessary especially for
um trans and non-binary people to to
kind of get this representation of love
and happiness it's not the main focus
you know does it come up maybe the
season maybe stuff do come up you know
but we are people who deserve to you
know have happiness as well and I love
how that is the ongoing thing with with
love I know we're here talking about
season two yes we're already crossing
our fingers for season three what would
you want to see Soul do I would love to
see maybe How would how would they
integrate a pride event with family
members will come with family members
would be involved I would love to see
this family at pride of course I don't
know I would love to see this family of
Pride that that is yes and I've already
talked about you because this is a
family where they'd all go right
outside look like and how wonderful and
how beautiful would that be I would love
to see Jorge and Henry maybe think about
starting a family I would love to see
Lily get some roots of her own
vacation
yeah okay let's go on Amazon we want to
do White Lotus
no one dies
it could be like the Real Housewives of
Portland and we just go on vacation yes
we love that
thank you